it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week you head to the open
Gotham City for the conclusion of
Rocksteady Studios Arkham Knight trilogy
scarecrow is back with all the sludge of
the Arkham Asylum inmates criminals
scurrying around Gotham City and the
infamous evils known as Harley Quinn the
penguin to face and the Riddler there's
a new gadgets while gliding ability
allowing you to use batarangs grapnel
guns or line launchers while gliding
gracefully to your final destination
you'll get the usual utility belt filled
with all sorts of knickknacks but nobody
cares because there's a Batmobile enjoy
it in all its glory be the bat on the
twenty-third also this week you get the
Gothic supernatural hack-and-slash that
is devil may cry for special edition
you'll be reunited with your love of
guns and swordplay with a deep combat
system but the special part is the three
new playable characters Virgil lady and
Trish Virgil is a close-range technical
fighter while lady uses a rocket
launcher and grappling wire but Trish
takes it home with a demonic sword
sparta that can fight on its own while
Trish fights alongside it new characters
along with Nero combined to create any
combos you've been itching to try start
combo chaining on the twenty-third
anyone who has final fantasy 14 around
reborn can pick up the dlc heavens Ward
this week there's new adventures waiting
for you in the city-state of ish guard
while you fight off some pissed-off
dragons exclusive items include a flying
Griffin that you can ride on and some
other stuff seriously it's an in-game
flying Griffin you can fly on you're
gonna want to get your Griffin on the
twenty-third but what if you want to
play a game this week and you have no
money well planetside 2 is aunt has
always been free so long as you know
microtransactions will exist along the
edges of space you might remember the
game on PC since it launched almost
three years ago yes it's been a while
but now it's coming to ps4 so you can
enjoy the MMOFPS on current gen console
one thing to note if your previous
player on PC your
currency and your character stay on that
machine the pc version uses daybreak
cash whereas the ps4 version uses battle
cash so you'll have to start fresh but
hey haven't we all wanted to start new
once in our lives start controlling
territories on the 23rd finally get out
of your garage and onto the streets with
ride burning out onto pc and current and
last gen consoles the game will have for
racing modes over 100 motorcycles that
range from super bikes to historical
hogs and online multiplayer so you can
ride or die with friends you can
customize both your rider and your
vehicle and with the large number of
tracks you could choose to take a ride
on the countryside or race under the big
lights in the city pop a wheelie on the
23rd for further details visit gamespot
com release states are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week
you